si deben ayudar a los más vulnerables a
adaptarse al cambio climático dijo boris
johnson el mundo corre riesgos de
empeorar conflictos desplazamiento y la
inseguridad en general ha dicho que el
mundo debe tomar acciones concretas para
reducir las emisiones a cero para el
2050 este por supuesto es un asunto
prioritario para el mundo y por ello se
espera que en la cumbre con 26 que se
realizará en noviembre en glasgow aquí
en el reino unido se adopten medidas
urgentes quizás aunque alguien enviado
especial de la casa blanca para el clima
participó de este encuentro en medio de
un giro de la política medioambiental de
eeuu que podemos destacar de su
participación luisa
varios países del consejo de seguridad
saludaron a el regreso de eeuu al
acuerdo de parís especialmente francia
el john kerry dijo que para el
presidente yo vaivén el asunto climático
es prioritario tanto que sabe que no se
les puede desperdiciar ni un solo minuto
y por ello este es un asunto que es
política de estado dijo juncker y además
que eeuu sabe que debe de tratarse este
como un asunto multilateral en el que
deben participar todos los países para
lograr acciones concretas dijo además
que se deben reducir las emisiones a
cero para 2050 o antes en eso coincidió
con el reino unido y dijo que los 17
países grandes productores de estas
emisiones deben reducir por ejemplo el
uso del carbón